ίσως ξεκινάτι πουμε το πρβλημα ου είναι ελέγχεται έγται πόυ την ασθυνομία τεράστιον κεφαλων οι
φυλακές όμως δύο με τρεις ιζηκήζεις καιγαπιτεθησία πρότησης μισμα πόυ την αρχή οι βαρεπινίτες και
σοβίες πριαφίουν που την περιοκή του αγιονρέ πνικινούν άλλες κεντρικές φυλακές δεύτεροι πρέπει να πεινοικοποιηθεί
ι κατοχή και η χρήση του κινητού εντο σκεντρικό φυλακού που δεν υπάρχει είναι επιθα
αρχικόν αδική μας σήμερα και τρίδω δεν μπορεί να περιμένουμε που ένα δεσμοφύλακα ναμε απαίνανται
που εκατόν παριπινίτες κ να περιμένουμε ότι ένα επιβάλλει την τάξεη και τ τά αρτό
για να το πουμε ένα το ξέρεις ο κόσμος καλι το οποίο να εναι ξέρει
ο κόσμος ότις το εξωτοριγογίνεται και στις κυπριακές φυλακές γίνεται είναι ότι σε όλες τες
φυλακές του κόσμου υπάρχουν δύο οιδον υπαλλίλι αυτοί που βρίσκονται εντός τωνκτυρίου οι οποι είναι
αυτοί που είαι ισοφρονιστικοί που ίναι μαζί όλη ημέρα με τους βάρει πινήτες με τους
αυτούς που είναι κατάδικοι αλλά υπάρχουν και ο άλλοη ομάδα που είναι αυτοή που είναι
έξω ιδη σοφρονιστική υπαλλήλι που θα μπούν μέσα να κάμουν τες έρευνες που δεν έχουν
επαφή με των με τον κατάδικο που δεν τον γνωρίζει ο κατατηγος ολλά αυτά να
τα λέμε εμάστε μικρόστοπος περιμένουμε κοι απεδούμε που κάποιον να γάμουν τη δουγιά τους αλλά
τα αυτό χρόνα πρέπει να τους διούμε και θα καταλέλαα εφόδια και τις δυνατότηδες δεν
θα μιλήσω για το απενεργοποίηση το σύστημα κινίήο τουλεφώνου αυτό είναι μια παριά ιστορία θεωρώ
ότι είναι πάρα πολύ τυσκολον να εφαρμοστεί στις κεντρικές φυλακές α και που βρίσκονται και
είναι ξεκάθαρον πλέον ότι το πενίντα τις εκατον ήσων το οργανομένο εγκλήματος να είναι από
τις καντρκές φυλαγές είπεπριν για ακόματα για διάφορα προβλήματα παρεμβάσεις που να δημιουργούν πρόβλημα να
πόε κα στην εστυνομία υπάρχουν α πααυτά τα απόματα ναι παρεμβάσεις για διαροχρονικά ακούμε να
ια προαγωγές ι ότι δήποτε προγές μεταθές ναι ναι είναι είναι ένα πρόβλημα αυτόνια τηνι
λειτουργεία ενώς συνόλου καίσως και το μεγαλύτερο συνόλο στη χώρα μας είναι επεντέμειση ε